welcome back to new rock stars just like
arthur harrow a once disciple obama
found himself becoming the avatar of
vomit i've become mt's avatar and i'm
now here to consume all of your rogue
series yes feed them to me
ah i'm off-screen producer brandon and
going rogue with me today and flying in
on her golden wings it's whitney van
laningham hello whitney hello the screen
isn't wide enough for you to see me
flapping my wings but i am but i am we
can imagine those beautiful golden wings
shining in the sun blocking bullets
thankfully thank god those were
bulletproof dude bulletproof wings
sounds great
uh i don't want that so bad you can fly
and not get shot perfect perfect that's
the perfect combination it really i
think everyone agree that's the perfect
scenario yeah that's the one thing
spirit airlines won't guarantee they'll
fly you there but you
if you pay for the upgrade you don't get
shot guys trust me trust me just gotta
remember to pay for the upgrade wow big
bucks brandon over here
you know when i'm flying on spirit i fly
like a millionaire that should be the
slogan for spirit fly like a millionaire
or risk gun injury yeah fly like a
millionaire we can't guarantee you won't
get shot no middle ground but they're
all middle seats baby spirits
uh
uh of course someone i would always
trust to pick me up from the airport and
not shoot me in the face
it's matt acevedo hello matt hey yeah
thanks man i would pick you up from the
airport i would even drive to lax for
you brandon whoa whoa that is huge that
means huge i'm gonna keep that it's on
camera you don't need to pay for gas you
know i got you yeah i got you whoa
whoa
oh my gosh that's very kind of you uh i
live in northridge so it's gonna be a
heck of a trip for you wow well we can
always listen to new rock stars on the
way down
we'll need a few episodes to listen to
in the car for sure uh and someone i
have personally seen do a full sprint
down the side of a pyramid it's tommy
bechdold hello tommy good to be here i
woke up this morning in this institution
dressed in all white with white walls
everywhere
uh i hope everything's okay i hear
they're playing bingo later
oh yes they are what's in the cup is it
wine or is it sand uh it's a mixture of
both i call it a sandy beach
it's one part wine cooler one part sand
one part malibu coconut rum delicious a
perfect way to start the day
well well everyone the series or
possibly season finale of moon night has
finally lit up the night sky and boy
what a finale it was from the sands of
the dua in the afterlife to back in the
london flat strapped to his bed mark and
stephen have made their piece and are
doing a one-man version of the odd
couple but wait this body has a stowaway
or two that leads us to our first topic
today who is in control okay what's the
balance now for mark steven and jake do
mark and stephen know anything about
jake do they know he's still there what
did layla see when jake took over during
that battle and she was pinned up
against a van getting shot point blank
with her her thankfully bulletproof
wings uh uh do mark and steven know that
kanchu is still bonded with the part of
them how do we think this new
arrangement is working out i was gonna
say you know that i'm sure you guys
already know what my first question is i
probably don't have to say it but
like
when steven and mark jerk off now do
they have to think about the same thing
like do they have to be like picturing
mentally the same scenario for them to
both come or is it like one one of them
is like
mock stop it stop wanking to feet you
know like is that like do one of them
have like a weird thing and the other
one doesn't mark's a footballer
mark's a foot man in my opinion
[Laughter]
okay okay i kind of imagined it like a
pacific rim thing you know where it's
like like you know they go into the
pacific rim you know robot and they're
drift compatible yeah that's right
that's right yeah no siri i gotta turn
this off cause siri keeps things from
talking to it
get out of here maybe me and siri are
one that's what's would you like to
watch pacific rim
all right brandon i'm going to give it
to you straight here i think that gets
me straight i think jake
is in control i think mark is the alpha
being
but i believe
mark b just based on conscious saying
mark has no idea
how broken of a person he is or whatever
uh
uh whatever that line is i'm
paraphrasing i think mark is in control
uh as i said on our smash hit show the
break room yesterday i believe that jake
lockley
is not a known public persona i believe
jake lockley impersonates mark spector
when while still being a separate
personality inside of mark's head to the
outside world i believe he is received
as mark spector and i've also been uh
never been more confident that jake
killed leyla's father because i think
i think that's what leila saw
when jake took control in the fight in
the streets of cairo he just savagely
murdered everyone around perhaps even an
innocent civilian or two pushing a cart
you know trying to sell some like
italian ice or something some ice cream
truck man just gets a right the throat
so i think she saw such savage you know
murder that that it was like scary to
her and i believe if they do do a season
two she'll put two and two together and
realize that there is this one side of
mark at least one side that is a savage
unrepentant killer yeah that's an
interesting point tommy so do you think
that jake
put a memory of like bushman killing
leila's dad into mark or mark just
assumes that he doesn't remember and he
assumes that's what happens i think jake
and kanchu have the true relationship no
i think i think jake kills whoever
conscious wants and conscious tells mark
that he only kills bad people and like
you know
kanchu has mark feeling like uh the
punisher or something like i'm only
taking out the trash but then jake is
like you want me to kill senator i'd
love to kill a senator you want me to
kill those kids too that'd be fun no
problem yo you want to do two every
state's got two come on let's go i'll
kill them yeah i'd kill them all i
definitely dig that theory uh i i also
agree that jake is the one that's kind
of in control i think that you know he
kind of appears when both of them show
signs of weakness so i think that maybe
there was a moment when he was with the
mercenaries group that maybe he couldn't
go through with it and like that you
know this is that's how he came to be
maybe he thought about uh i know machete
or some movie and it was like this is
who i need to be to get this job done
but i agree that like that he's
definitely the one in charge and
conscious just playing them both uh i
don't think that they know i think that
they think they're free i think they
think they don't have the power of
conscious anymore i think they're uh um
i think they're in for a rude awakening
um yeah part of me thinks that konchi
wanted mark and steven to kind of like
think that they were the one once in
control because like maybe they needed
to be
like work together or get to this point
to like maybe allow uh
uh
excuse me jason
jake what's his name jake jake
jason lockley everybody jason locklear
you know famous guy in a hockey mask
jason lockley
drowned at the camp
like i think he's always been in there
but i think having them in sync like
that it makes it easier to like get jake
to come out uh that's kind of where i
think i think conscious wanted this to
happen he wanted stephen and uh
stephen and mark to get like really
close and to have that quick
because they're kind of succe
they kind of keep each other busy right
yeah right i i think man i think you're
exactly right i think i think like
getting them to believe that they're out
of the game allows him to just summon
jake to do whatever he wants that was
literally exactly what i was gonna say i
felt like the moment
that stephen was like alright you're
dealing with me now and we're gonna make
a deal i felt like immediately conscious
was just like
okay yeah sure you guys are free
mark and stephen are free to go but he
knew that he still had jake lockley and
so i think that that was the only reason
why he
let them out of the game was because he
was like you're not out of the game
nobody's out of the game this is
ridiculous like yeah like he was just
like you guys can think you're out of
the game but you will never be out of
the game because i have jake lockley
i i i think that uh like there's gonna
be a point where they're just gonna
they're gonna have to be fine with
themselves right they're gonna have to
like look i'm a firm believer of the
power of friendship baby and you know
what's gonna what's gonna happen they're
gonna help they're gonna help jake out
dude they're gonna they're gonna like be
like hey jake hey you're a part of us
but like hey maybe we shouldn't kill so
much and then we're gonna be like best
buds he'll be the brooding one mark will
be like the you know the the leonardo
one and then uh you know and then
stephen will be stephen i think they're
good they're gonna work together at some
point i actually think that
i i like that but i'm going to say i
disagree i think if they make a season 2
or a movie it's going to be a two-on-one
how do we
i think because i think once all of the
true actions of mark specter have been
revealed as jake lockley as mark spector
as uh stephen grant and as whoever else
if there's even a fourth worse or
different personality
i think that that's going to irreparably
damage his relationship with layla and i
think there's one person that can get in
that brain
and kind of fix things and that's
charles xavier and i believe at some
point
they're going to have to
go to professor x and have him go inside
the brain and remove or permanently
almost like in heroes uh the tv show
heroes where they trapped sylar inside
of uh nathan's brain uh that's a deep
cut for those of you who uh dude
uh but uh
i think they're going to like basically
put the jake lockley personality to
sleep permanently or
permanently in comic book movie terms in
order to allow stephen and mark to be a
good guy because you can't have i mean
you can have but like if you want him to
be a protagonist in a thing
he can't be a bloodthirsty remorseless
killer which it appears jake lockley is
yeah
yeah i mean they're going to like lock
up that sarcophagus oh i was just gonna
say um i have a question for you guys
so
when i was watching the finale so like
obviously in episode five we saw
uh the two brothers like go into the
cave and then the little brother died
and blah blah and obviously like outside
the cave it looked like they were like
country bird bones you know
and i was thinking what do you guys
think about this
do you think that that was jake lockley
who dragged his little brother into the
cave to kill him oh
oh
concho was there the whole time kanchu
could have been instructing him since he
was oh my god
and was like do it the cave is gonna
flood take your little brother in there
everyone will think it's an accident
like i wonder i wonder that's uh that's
that's start well
i you know you bring up that scenario
right and we wonder is that memory how
real is that memory right is kanchu
making this memory for mark i was
wondering is like the little brother was
that the jake personality oh right um
fearless
yeah kind of like the fearless adventure
and like kanchu wanted that personality
as the avatar not mark and so
you know by thinking by mark thinking he
kills his little brother he thought he
maybe put away this part of his
personality but it's still alive it's
still there i don't know this show is so
weird you don't know what was real or
what's happening i'm just wondering you
know i was a little you know you got you
kind of alluded to it
alluded to it earlier whitney i was
wondering like how does layla feel about
this situation is she still with mark
and stephen like yeah they obviously
know something's up they they chain
themselves to the bed they know they
can't be trusted still
so like how does layla feel like about
these two dudes
who are like all over her now
where is she like because she clearly
did not like go sleep over at her
boyfriend's house ex-husband whatever's
house after maybe she it's early she
could be out getting coffee to surprise
him but she's coming back up the stairs
maybe she's getting coffee to surprise
him a little french toast
i don't know she seemed to never quite
recover from watching what he did to
everyone on the street like she got like
they did the spell together but she
never seemed fully back on board with
him beyond that point like the way she
was looking at him that never changed
and then we never got any sort of
resolution on that yeah and on top of
that to add to that tommy like they also
never
confronted the fact that he was there
when her mother or her father was
murdered when layla's father was they
never really dealt with that like it was
loose and then he dies you know i mean
yeah he was like he was like we'll talk
about it later and then he just dies
like that's an important conversation to
pick back up at some point which i mean
god men will do anything to not confront
their issues right it's so
true literally die before they talk
about their problems babe babe there's
giant gods fighting we don't have time
to have this disgusting right now okay
baby just give me a minute
babe babe not now okay my bros are over
i got i got stephen over in my head game
john
babe the game's on babe come on
i'm throwing i'm throwing knives into
people's chests come on babe now's not
the time i gotta break a new shopki not
now not now honey i do wonder like if i
was mark and stephen before you know
right after that i would sit layla down
and be like okay tell me everything you
saw during that fight please yeah me too
cause i'd be like what what was that
what did i do part of the denial that
allows jake lockley to stay separate is
that they don't ask questions like they
know like mark
stephen might be too
innocent
but mark might know and be like if i
don't ever
ask then i don't have to take
responsibility for what i deep down know
is true right plausible deniability true
yeah do you get like uh what is it can
you plead the fifth against uh
was it like you can't incriminate your
other personality in a murder well you
cannot be forced yeah you cannot be
forced to testify against your spouse
that's right
oh okay so i guess if like if you have a
different personality you cannot be
forced to testify against your
personality yeah do you think do you
guys think mark and stephen no do they
know conscious still in there or do they
do you think
they think he's gone gone i think they
think they're free oh there's gone gone
yeah they think he's gone
a hundred percent they think he's gone
but he's not he's not he's not gone i
mean look how happy they are like
they're they're going through their day
i mean we have this scene where they're
in control of uh
i don't know what you call it like the
the
like that's where i got a little
confused like did was that a dream when
they went back to the the mental ward
room or was that them like just losing
the abilities of khanshu or
i think the way eric and mt kind of
talked about it on inside marvel was
interesting it was like the idea that
like
everything in harrow's office was
separate from the boat
uh
psych ward and like the stuff inside the
office was within mark stevens
head so if you have me it's like the
second level of inception or whatever
like that was the snow base right and
then they got the hotel on the outside
so it's like they had to resolve the
stuff inside the head and then they can
resolve the afterlife uh and get out so
it kind of worked backwards i guess so
when they
trap ahmed inside of harrow
inside of the head they they closed him
off too because i think harold had some
agency inside the head of mark and
stephen when they were in the afterlife
so yeah that was very confusing man uh
and i don't know if i explained it very
well but like they kind of had to like
switch the roles there yeah and i think
that just that that scene just showed
that they've they've come to terms that
this is the end of this chat they they
believe that this is closure for them
and they're all happy they trip over
themselves oh like you know this is our
life you know
like please please
stephen you masturbate first please
don't please no please after you insist
what are you saying that's what i'm
saying
but yeah they think he's gone they think
he's gone dude
and i'm gonna stick to it guys i think
that jake was a child murderer i'm
calling it now i think that there's
i mean that's that's like a wild theory
and that's great that is a really rogue
theory
i love that
well baby ted bundy little baby ted
bundy baby bundies they're making dreams
come true
baby bundies they'll follow you after
school
can we as a society society stop putting
these serial killers on like pedestals
yeah it's so weird tv shows and stuff i
mean we all love reading about it uh we
are obsessed with the extremes of
uh what humans will do to each other but
we gotta stop we gotta stop putting
these serial killers on a pedestal oh no
that the ted bundy movie with zac efron
where they made him look like a scamp
like he was just a little scamp but it's
like no he was like a murderer like you
can't make this movie you can't give him
abs like stop it like yeah like worlds
were destroyed yeah he's like getting
out of a pool toweling off they're like
[Music]
it was like that ted that ted bundy
portrayal was
akin to ashton kutcher's portraying
steve jobs in that bible oh like it was
the same vibe
yeah
yeah i would think we all
forgot about coach uh ashton kutcher's
steve jobs i have not one for the
history books uh well these are some
great rogue theories guys i i really
hope we get more of this show and get
some of these uh ideas answered matt i'm
gonna give you three rogue points uh for
your theories there uh uh whitney i mean
i'm gonna give you four rogue points uh
for for jake the child killer i mean
that's dark that's a dark stuff and i
like that uh but tommy i'm gonna give
you five rogue points i love this idea
of jake jake just pretending to be mark
is like a great idea i'm like using all
these documents and stuff and like
people just think mark's this like
really bad guy i really like that it's
very smart that also makes me think jake
set up the date i bet jake did set up
jake said that i think jake absolutely
set up the date and it would explain why
jake's limo has the license plate
spectre because if he's impersonating
mark spector
that would make sense
i love it i also love the idea that he
wants to drive the limo
he wants to be the driver
yeah he's like i drive this thing yeah
yeah i like feeling in control that's
the height of luxury for some and i
support it i mean uh a rolls-royce is a
driver's car right it's it's a car to be
driven in also we don't know if kanchu
has all his finger bones they might just
be floating so if he just goes through a
steering wheel
just can't grab him
yeah he can't
uh well up next we're gonna talk about
the khanshu kaiju but first check out
newrockstarsmerch.com for all of our
awesome merch related to moon night
especially our latest obsession shirt
the tomb of the moon god once it's gone
it's gone for good and also by the time
this episode airs we'll probably have
some new doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness merch available at
newrockstarsmerch.com be sure to check
that out it's a great way to support the
channel we also want to thank expressvpn
using the internet with expressvpn is
like going to sleep without chaining
your leg to a pole in your house most of
the time you'll probably be fine but
what if one day you sleepwalk into
traffic or steal a rare egyptian
artifact it's better to be careful
especially when it's as simple as using
expressvpn every time you connect to an
unencrypted network in cafes hotels
airports your online data is not secured
any hacker on the same network can gain
access and steal your personal data but
expressvpn creates a secure encrypted
tunnel between your device and the
internet so they can't they'll never be
able to it'd take a hacker with a super
computer over a billion years to get
past expressvpn's encryption and the
planet is barely going to make it
another 20 years so you'll be safe
expressvpn works on all of your devices
the phone the laptop the tablet even on
your smart tv and it's so easy to use
just fire up the app and click one
button to get protected i like using
expressvpn when i do my online shopping
especially when i'm out and about and
using public wi-fi on my phone i don't
trust it so i use expressvpn get an
extra three months of expressvpn free at
expressvpn.com
rogue that's expressvpn.com
expressvpn.com
hey folks it's spring did you know that
or is it spring you know sometimes it
feels like it's winter it's kind of cold
in burbank today sometimes it feels like
summer and it's it's super hot it can be
so difficult to find the right outfit in
the spring when every day is different
and weather can change at the drop of a
hat luckily parody makes it way easier
they make the perfect clothes for all
seasons verity is a family run brand
making high quality timeless clothing
with a modern design and functionality
it's that kind of effortless style you
want every time you go digging in your
closet maybe it's like a gorgeous print
and it looks like you you've had it for
years and it might be vintage but it
feels so great and it fits so well and
it was just made yesterday just for you
well that's verity these clothes are
great i got a pair of their all-day
shorts and i wore them from open to
clothes at disneyland and they held up
all day they felt great they were
lightweight they had a zipper in the
pocket so my my ticket didn't fall out
it was the perfect thing i love them
verity's so confident in the quality of
their stuff they have a lifetime
guarantee of quality they'll replace or
fix your clothes forever no matter what
talk about making it easier to get
dressed and right now fahrity is giving
all new rockstars fans 20 off that's 20
off head to faritybrand.com rogue and
use code rogue at checkout to snag 20
off all of your new spring staples
that's code rogue faraday
f-a-h-e-r-t-y brand dot com slash rogue
for 20 off again veritybrand.com
hey i've got a controversial take for
all of you moms are great my mom used to
make me homemade lunchables she refused
to buy them from the store she would cut
out the cheese and meat into cute little
shapes i mean can you believe that i
would never do that for a child but my
mom did it for me moms are also often
one of the few people in our lives who
still leave voicemails on our phones or
call us just to say hi so this mother's
day make that next mom call extra
special boil your mom with the gift of
quality premium wireless audio courtesy
of raycon raycon wireless earbuds are a
must-have for super moms all those
masters of multitasking who need to keep
their hands free with reikons they can
stay entertained listening to their
favorite podcasts or music plus take
phone calls with vivid voice technology
all hands-free uh raycons are
user-friendly for those moms who are
just switching to wireless earbuds easy
to set up easy to use and seamless
bluetooth pairing plus they come in a
bunch of fun color options but you can
find a mom color that suits her
personality and style with optimized gel
tips for the perfect in-ear fit these
earbuds are so comfortable and they will
not budge trust me she won't have a hard
time getting them out even though you
know moms have sometimes a hard time
getting rid of that idea that uh you
should have like six kids these won't
come out but maybe that thought will
finally come out of their head for the
mom on the go raycons offer eight hours
of playtime and 32 hour battery life
with their compact portable charging
case they're priced just right you get
quality audio at half the price of other
premium audio brands and raycon's
everyday earbuds have over forty nine
thousand five star reviews perfectly
fitting for a five star mom my mom's got
some ray cons she uses them all the time
when she calls me uh so she can keep
gardening she loves her geraniums and
wants to keep chatting while she's
planting tell mom how much you love her
and make sure she hears it in crystal
clear audio quality with raycon go to
buy raycon.com rogue theory to get 15
off your mother's day order that's by
raycon.com
rogue theory all right here's something
i know for sure these gods need some
therapy come on
get some therapy gods they're out here
fighting in the streets while they're 50
feet tall this is going to be our second
topic for today what are the
ramifications of this khanshu ahmed
battle okay what more can the citizens
of the mcu live through
do do we think the public could see
these giant gods duking it out next to
the pyramids uh if they could or even if
they couldn't truly they saw all the
purple souls leaving people's bodies you
know what are the larger ramifications
for this moment in the mcu
is anyone ever going to talk about this
again
how do we think this fight played out do
we think people could see them well i
think how the mcu kind of handles this
is rather than a
like
long meditation into the like city-wide
response and how people handled it
they'll give us the isolated story of
like one guy
whose wife was killed is collateral
damage and that causes him to become an
evil scientist and do something bad to
thwart like bucky barnes in something
like a year from now or two years from
now they don't really ever seem to do
like
i mean like you know the dc tried to do
that with um with justice league where
they had like bruce wayne carrying
people from the wreckage of superman or
maybe batman vs superman that was rather
i can't remember those movies are
all such classics burned into my brain
but like where bruce wayne is like
trying to like do a civilian response
and creates a foundation for the
survivors of the superman zod fight
i just think in this case
marvel tends to not like they just kind
of ignore that like they're just like no
the battle's over and good defeated evil
so the end's justified much like uh
ahmet the ends have justified the means
sorry about your city uh don't worry
someone will come in or we also have
that the tva just cleans things up too
but we don't have that anymore but that
was kind of explained in loki it was
like oh they'll come in and just fix it
uh i i kind of think that i don't think
they could see
uh konshu and ahmet fighting i kind of
feel like it was more like a natural
disaster or like heavy winds or
something um
you know maybe a few special people
could see him but i don't think the
majority could but i think they could
see but i do think that they could see
mark fighting against harrow uh through
the streets and that's like that's like
normal everyday stuff in the mcu um i do
think though that with right man here's
i'm like i'm getting fired up because i
think this is gonna happen i'm pretty
stoked about this i think i think that
the results of this with the celestial
coming out of the of the freaking earth
and eternals with whatever happens in
multiverse of madness there's definitely
paranoia is or paranoia that's too but
paranormal activity is on the map uh
things that like you know nick fury when
he wanted the avengers to get together
it's because he wanted to protect the
earth from extraterrestrial beings like
who's going to protect the earth from
that uh i think we're going to get to
the point where we're going to be
assembling a team uh we're getting
what's that game called i wrote it down
yeah midnight suns is coming out so uh
and i think that we're going to be
getting the midnight suns coming
together kind of as like the paranormal
response to like all of these threats
like doctor strange uh you know mark uh
uh moon knight could be in there uh
bring uh um uh uh what like i think
their names like uh eliza bloodstone in
there uh you know like bring all these
characters even morbius was a member of
the midnight suns at one point uh and i
don't know if they're gonna bring that i
don't know what they're gonna do
but i think we're kind of getting to
that point where we're going to get more
team-based things building up to these
kind of crossover events we're going to
get young avengers like this is the
response to all of this is someone
assembling a team probably dr strange of
getting these people to come together to
fight against like paranormal stuff i
like that idea a lot i mean that's what
we're all hoping for that's how we can
get more more moon night right it's like
by having the midnight sun show up just
bringing in like a bunch of other people
yeah bring johnny blaze back you know i
thought that there was a chance that
that's who was gonna be
uh
taking harrow when they just showed the
leather jacket
i was like yeah it's gonna be good ryder
and then
because we had we had theorized that you
don't even need to cast an actor yet
because you could just have him get in
the limo roll down the thing and he's
just got the flaming skull head which is
not safe for inside a car but you know
no no don't put that inside of a car it
would be so like i mean
i don't know man like robbie reyes was i
thought the guy who they got to play
robbie reyes in uh agents of shield was
great and i was pretty like i also was
like man is this robbie reyes is he
gonna show up but uh no he didn't which
is that canon it's like loosely i don't
know i don't know agents of shield is
unconfirmed yeah i think i think the way
they probably phrase it now right tommy
is that like it's a
it's like a splintered time it's a
branch timeline something
yeah it's a branch timeline like the
same way cap going back and being with
peggy is like a branch like this is
agents of seal was its own branch uh
because we saw something weird in like
the finale right like the triskelion was
still there or something strange like
that
the kind of the show saying like hey we
knew we were supposed to be part of the
mcu but now we're not officially anymore
but
so we're taking agency and saying our
triskelion's still there that's right
you can't take it away from us and never
take it from us so do you so if if they
couldn't see the gods if they couldn't
see these 50-foot tall gods i asked this
question uh tommy yesterday on the break
room check out the break room every day
uh on new rockstars youtube but so if
people could see the purple souls going
up and then going into amit's mouth do
they just see like the souls going into
the sky and they're just like
disappearing like a at the spot of
vomit's mouth and like also how many of
them were unexpected like how many how
many people like lost like an ant that
they didn't realize was like you know
running running like a game like like a
[ __ ] fighting syndicate or something and
was like oh god
and trudy up in the sky now yeah
lots of people lost their [ __ ] fighting
ants that night
let's pour one out for all the
cockfighting ants who died that evening
cockfighting ants by the way is what
mark likes to watch when he goes at it
uh exactly
[Laughter]
come on mark you gotta clear the search
history geez i don't know you guys i
know that this is like a really boring
basic answer but my answer to this
question is
i just think that the people in the mcu
are
used to it by now i think that nobody's
freaking out at all i think that they
are so jaded that they saw the souls
going into the night sky and they were
like well at least this time a giant
celestial didn't erupt the earth at
least
wait
wait one second yeah or at least it
isn't half of all life disappearing this
time
are you telling me
that people are willing to ignore
massive deaths
and continue with life as usual
just out of some sort of survival
mechanism knowing that if they were to
take precautions
not as many people would die
you're telling me that an entire
world of people would be more apt to
just press on with life acting as though
there was not a a worldwide i don't know
i don't want to say uh pandemic but just
a massive
issue going on worldwide and that the
simpler more selfish response is just to
continue eating your chicken cutlets and
going to uh going out to the dairy queen
not wearing your anti amit masks i don't
know i don't know if i can buy that this
seems yeah i don't know this seems a
little too far-fetched for me it's just
a superhero fantasy and this is a really
rogue theory
you're going to rogue whitney i don't
know i think
you've lost me here i'm not willing to
believe it
everyone would [ __ ] ignore it nobody
would [ __ ] care nobody would care
they would still go on with their lives
i think i think what happens in the real
world 100 proves your theory correct i
think your theory has been proven
over the last two years yes i kind of
want to know like if all these people
are going to commit some sort of major
crime like what what quantify is that
because there was a lot of souls there's
a lot of souls coming up well yeah we we
don't know the rules this is like the
good place right we don't know how you
get determined to get into the the field
of reads like like if if ahmet finds out
that i still shoplift from support from
sephora from time to time am i gonna
like get got for that because i believe
you should always keep your hand in the
game so you don't get rusty that's right
i mean yeah we don't know if the indian
has like updated their rules over the
years right like uh you know how did
they how did they judge social media
right yeah it's like new rules
if you uh
if you don't get expressvpn
to block your browser
and you buy some tootsie from mexico to
have a little fun at your cousin's
wedding
you're going to hell from amit emmett's
taking your soul i mean all these
actions make me think that like the mcu
as we get ready for thor 4 right if is
gore gonna show up on earth and all the
people be like yeah kill some of these
guys they're out of control please do
something gore yeah dude honestly we've
got we've got like a [ __ ] ton of them
down in egypt who have been wreaking
absolute havoc so please his name is
khanshu go get him
my grandma has a co-morbidity she's more
likely to get eaten by gore the god
butcher anyway uh it's no problem my
cousin has type 2 diabetes so obviously
gore the god butcher is going to target
him first
no problem
we haven't really even seen like like
you know new asgard got introduced uh
three years ago has it been three years
right and like we still don't really
know how it fits you know we haven't
seen them like at play yet which is
interesting you know we're about to
i think it was no way home there was
like one little headline that was like
political turmoil in new asgard and
clearly from the trailer of thor four
you know it's getting built up it's a
tourist destination they got cruise
liners docking there now i mean yeah
this could be a
does just norway get a cut of this money
like are they paying up to the country
or do they consider themselves a
sovereign state we we've totally
transitioned this rogue this rogue
theory over to talking about asgard
are they a sovereign state
let's get some political strategists in
here next week for rogue theory and have
them talk right i mean is is valkyrie
like a weapon of mass destruction or are
they in the game with like all the other
countries who have nukes at this point
are they nato you know we don't know
what korg's capable of yeah yeah did
they join nato answer the question feige
uh so do we think like
to talk to what kind of what tommy was
saying is
is anyone gonna talk about this fight
ever again or
will they come clean to the people if
they didn't see the gods fighting how
much is the public gonna find out about
like the events of moon night very
little like nothing i think i think
we'll move on immediately there'll be a
news headline in the background no one
outside of egypt at all i think in my
opinion i don't think that anyone who
wasn't like there is even gonna hear
about it because it's just like
oh no like what they're gonna get like a
headline from cairo that's like oh no
new mcu thing happened wha and it's like
yeah then
if anybody even saw that they'd be like
yeah par for the course whatever was
once yeah it was a tuesday i kind of
think that uh that egyptian girl uh it
probably took a video and like he's
gonna put it on tick tock and they're
gonna blow up and picked up
like dang yeah yeah look at these new
superheroes yeah the any ad blowing up
on tick-tock
that's how we get the youth back into
religion
that's how we get some new avatars now
that all our avatars are dead
all our avatars are dead they're dead
if if those souls didn't come back right
uh
the ones that were taken by ahmed if
they if they are stuck in like the do i
this could be like a high level event
though for the mcu because remember when
they were showing in civil war like all
the tragedies and like why the avengers
were bad and like sokovia i think the
death count was like around 200 or maybe
under 200 and i was like that was a
piece of land falling from the sky and
crashing to the ground so if a couple
hundred people just died in cairo that's
a big event that that's pretty major i
think they would have to address it at
some point so i don't know
uh but i love all these theories uh so
i'm gonna give tommy i'm gonna give you
one rogue point i think we can't ignore
it we got to move on uh someone's got to
talk about it someone's got to talk
about that's out there uh whitney i'm
going to give you two rogue points
uh for for your theories and and matt
i'm gonna give you three rogue points
which will bring us all up to six rogue
points six six six
as we head into our rogue question
we're gonna enter the multiverse of
madness for our rogue question so we
need the devil's number uh to be able to
do it so at the time we're recording
this episode of of rogue theory we have
not seen doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness yet we're all
seeing it this this day at some time uh
we will be out there amongst you in the
theater uh so we're not going to give a
spoiler right now
you can find us i'll give you a treat
uh-oh everyone's going to be hunting
down whitney
we're not going to spoil the movie
because none of us have seen it but i
want to hear some rogue and i mean
really rogue theories for a member of
the illuminati i want to hear something
too crazy to be true but so crazy that
it's too big to fail okay so give me
like your rokus member of the illuminati
that people are going to be ripping the
back of their seat cushions off throwing
popcorn into the air going so crazy when
this person shows up in the illuminati
okay i'll go one that just makes no
sense
but would be incredible
um this is a man who recently joined the
mcu
uh this is a man who left
uh
a certain uh movie studio franchise uh
thing that
when he left it was at the top of its
game and it's only gone downhill since
he's playing a different character in
the mcu but why not
have christian bale cameo as dc's bruce
wayne the world's greatest detective
pulled in
from the multiverse to sit on the one of
the illuminati chairs
we're talking like a retired retired
batman hanging out in london and all of
a sudden like a portal opens up and he's
like you're in the illuminati buddy
that's right he's having tea with
catwoman tipping his cap to michael kane
bam he's in the illuminati yeah bale the
christian bale nolan verse batman oh
you said what's the craziest i love that
yeah that's crazy i love it i love this
i love it all right i'll go next okay so
this one
he's having the time of his life we
talked about him briefly before the
episode i'm talking about everyone's
favorite brendan fraser as himself he's
going full nick cage on this it's like
brendan fraser get on in here
the actor playing himself he's having
the time he's a resurgence and he's just
on the illuminati he has one great great
quip and like a smolder at the camera
and like there he is on the illuminati
brendan freaking frasier
yeah i like it i like it yeah i'd almost
like it if it was george of the jungle
yeah he had somehow like swung into the
multiverse
like his practical
practical
jungle brain makes the makes the uh the
illuminati better he understands nature
yeah he understands how to commune with
the jungle of any multiverse i would
personally love to see him on like on
like the panel of the illuminati and
someone goes george how did you get here
and he goes george just lucky i guess
i would love that
that is perfect
that's perfect
that's amazing that's amazing and it'll
explain
his like his his disappearance from the
screen you know that's what happened
yeah yeah yeah i love it yeah i love
this idea that's a great one matt all
right guys i'm gonna tell the truth
about who's on the illuminati
uh
we've we've been hiding it for a while
here at new rock stars but uh
you know him
you love him
star of stage and screen
abbott elementary the jimmy kimmel show
with a golden bikini his name is tommy
bechdold ladies and gentlemen
i always knew it
i'll never tell
you'll never see me whitney or brandon
ever again anywhere
ah this answer is perfect because it
panders through my massive ego
well i mean these were some incredible
answers to the wrong question i'm giving
everyone a point everyone's a winner
uh in honor of multiverse of madness
coming out uh today yes everyone wins
today yes uh and that's it for this
episode of rogue theory thank you to all
our guests today whitney van laningham
matt acevedo tommy beck told support our
channel by checking out all of our
awesome merch over at
newrockstarsmerch.com
if you've got thoughts on some of our
rogue theories or maybe you have some
rogue theories of your own you can share
them on our discord if you're over 18
click the link for the new rockstars
discord server uh down in the
description below and join the
conversation be sure to check out the
break room our daily live show streaming
every afternoon live from our
headquarters here at new rockstars on
our youtube channel follow me at
grindenberric follow new rockstars on
all our social platforms and be sure to
subscribe to our youtube channel right
here please see you next time have a
great day we love you goodbye
[Music]
you